[Music]
hey we've got a problem here what did
you do nothing the tax that's actor
Kevin Bacon of course in the Academy
award-winning film Apollo 13 that's
about the failed mission to the moon in
1970 which introduced us to the phrase
Houston we've had a problem as we've
been telling you this week the first
successful mission to put a man on the
moon was the year before in 1969 with
Apollo 11
bacon watched it unfold from his
family's basement in Philadelphia in
this special story for CTM bacon takes
us back to 1969 with a few of the years
other history makers he shows us how
landing on the moon influenced
technology and culture in the decades
that followed I remember as being a very
exciting moment all of a sudden this
place and this thing that we just looked
up at and just kind of dreamed about and
wrote songs about became something that
we had actually touched and I think that
that changed us pretty deeply it was a
monumental achievement in a year of
milestones we asked some of 1969's
history makers here on earth to share
their experience of seeing man make it
to the moon
he almost thought that you were watching
something unreal something you know that
it's not it really happening
his name is synonymous with speak Mario
Andretti had his first and only win at
the Indianapolis 500 1969 the
traditional sip of milk and milk never
tasted better astronauts actually
there's something there's a correlation
between our sport in so many ways the
danger aspect we'd all look at the moon
its daily affair and we did that Nancy
Nevins was the folksy front woman for
sweet water the band that was supposed
to open Woodstock traffic to reach the
venue made that impossible and then
people were abandoning their cars so
finally realized we are never gonna get
there sure a lot of people here that was
a greatest crowd
[Music]
the job
the myth winning the World Series in
six-man with a rival to man walking on
the moon Cleon Jones went deep into the
outfield to make the World Series
winning catch for the 1969 New York Mets
[Applause]
we had a charter plane and man we looked
up in Airport and we were watching man
walk on the moon so if that can happen
we can wake up tomorrow and be the best
team in baseball and ended a decade of
protests against an unpopular war in
Vietnam and uprisings over inequality in
several American cities
[Music]
detectives were turbulent in every sense
of the word
the deaths of President Kennedy his
brother Robert and civil rights leaders
Malcolm X Martin Luther King jr. also
weighed on the consciousness of the
nation America needed demand and welcome
to Munich no it was unifying and it was
hope now we're doing something now we're
gonna go somewhere now we're gonna be
somebody you can imagine how much pride
we all should have for our nation while
we are capable of we were the first ones
up there the moment man walked on the
moon also inspired pop culture for
decades there was the music and the
launch of music television MTV continues
to use the moon man as its annual award
and moonwalk that was born from that
otherwise who would ever thought about
walking or Lord right
[Music]
landing on the moon also marked a turn
towards advanced technology before long
the space race was no longer a
competition but a global collaboration
that pushes everybody you know to just
you know to just let's reach out for
something that seems to be unreachable
they get the rover up there recently and
all I love all that I eat that stuff up
it's just something that mankind wants
to conquer it tells us that we could do
anything we want to do
who knows where innovation will lead us
next it could be Mars but maybe most
encouraging is that the journey
continues it should make us feel small
and it should make us feel protective of
what we have here which i think is the
most important message that photo never
ceases to inspire me
thank you Kevin Bacon I love his boys I
never paid that much attention to Kevin
Bacon's voice when I'm watching the
movie he's got a beautiful voice and I
say as a Mets fan it's great to see
Cleon Jones and the whole idea that if
we could walk on the moon the Mets could
win the Pats give away the most
important achievements in in
twentieth-century America we do
something like put a man on the moon
again we need that in this country we
need that that unity that that sense of
purpose but if you remember as you
pointed out this week we there wasn't it
there wasn't a groundswell of support
for that idea at the time now it seems
kind of genius fun fact from Joe long
our producer who we all know do you know
that this is a 1960 ninth episode of CBS
this morning
1969 well that's really cool thank you
Joe long that's very cool yes this just
in and we'll be right back